our Western colleagues, especially from the USA, not
only arbitrarily establish such
rules, but also teach who
should implement them and how, who should behave and how they should
generally behave, and they say
this is all usually an openly
boorish manifestation of this
colonial
thinking. We seriously warn you who you
are
In general, what right do you have to
warn someone? It’s time to get rid of
this thinking of the era of
colonial
rule. I would like to say, so to speak, wipe your
eyes. This era is long over and will
never return. Our
understanding of civilization is completely
different, firstly, and
neither of them is better and  no worse than
the other, they have equal rights, how to express the
tea of ​​their cultures and traditions of their
peoples, our interlocutors in the West
seem to have completely forgotten that there are
such concepts as reasonable
self-restraints, compromises, readiness to
give in something in order to achieve
acceptable for everyone
clothes,
Ino push Accept at any cost Here and
now  their
interests if this is their choice, we’ll see what
comes of it, but we are not going to
impose ourselves on Europe if it doesn’t
want it. We don’t refuse it, we don’t
slam it shut, it’s poison
from us and it’s
not we who create this new iron curtain, but the
Europeans who
create it for themselves  at a loss and to your own detriment,
you understand that it
turned out that the competitiveness of the
European
economy fell Down And
the competitiveness of their main thing, in
fact, from the point of view of the economic
component of
competitors
and other countries, including in Asia, also
increased with their own
hands as a result of the loss of the loss of part of
their sovereignty with their own hands they
were forced  go to Making a decision to
your own
detriment. Well, why do we need such a desk? By and
large, the Ukrainian economy without an outward
being can no longer do everything
differently today, look there, everything
is balanced in general
externally and the budget is balanced in Ukraine;
macroeconomic indicators are
more or less torn out, but for  at the expense of what at the
expense of
monthly
multi-billion dollar only it will stop everything
in a week everything will fall all the
same applies to the defense system Well
imagine the supplies will stop
tomorrow there will be a week left
only when the ammunition runs out the
question is probably hanging in the air What
happened to the management of the company and so
on well we know  plane crash, the
head of the Investigative Committee reported to me
literally the other day that
fragments of hand grenades were found in the bodies of those killed in a plane crash. There was no
external influence on the plane,
this was not an already established fact, a fact,
but the result of an examination carried out by the
Investigative Committee of the Russian
Federation